[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
niedrige Sirin schönen guten Abend Katja
das basketballfieber in Deutschland das
steigermilch das steigt noch 90 Minuten
dann wird es ernst für das Team von
Gordon Herbert in Berlin wir schauen uns
das jetzt an im themenüberblick
und übernimmt die Kontrolle die
Regierung will den raffineriebetrieb im
brandenburgischen Schwedt sichern wenn
aus Russland kein Öl mehr kommt
gräberfund in der Ostukraine nach dem
Rückzug der russischen Armee aus Issum
ermitteln jetzt die ukrainischen
Behörden
und noch ein Schritt zum Finale für die
deutschen Basketballer geht es heute
gegen Spanien um den Einzug ins em
Endspiel
[Musik]
zum neuen Jahr wird kein russisches Öl
mehr nach Deutschland fließen wegen des
Öl Embargos gegen Russland und damit in
Raffinerien die russisches Erdöl
verarbeiten nicht das Licht ausgeht wird
die Bundesregierung mit dem heutigen Tag
dort die Kontrolle übernehmen bzw bei
deren Geschäften mitreden es geht um die
Raffinerien in Vorburg an der Donau
Karlsruhe und vor allem in Schwedt in
Brandenburg die Anlage dort gehört
mehrheitlich dem russischen
Staatskonzern rossniev sie produziert
große Mengen an Heizöl Benzin und Diesel
für den gesamten Nordosten Deutschlands
und um die Energiesicherheit zu
garantieren soll der Standort jetzt
vorübergehend von der Bundesnetzagentur
treuhänderisch verwaltet werden über die
Pläne Nicole Dieckmann
nicht nur das Öl in der PCK Raffinerie
in Schwedt ist Russisch sondern auch ihr
Mehrheitseigner trotzdem müsse hier nun
keine Angst mehr herrschen vor dem Öl
embargo das im Januar in Kraft tritt
sagt heute der Bundeskanzler
die Hängepartie ist zu Ende mit der
Treuhand ist es jetzt möglich dass
tatsächlich alle Investitionen ausgelöst
werden die wir brauchen für eine
langfristige Zukunftssicherung und mit
der Treuhand und den Entscheidung die
wir hier miteinander vorbereitet haben
ist auch gesichert dass kein
Arbeitnehmer in Schwedt Angst um seinen
Arbeitsplatz haben muss die
Bundesnetzagentur und damit das
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium übernimmt
nun erstmal die Kontrolle über zwei
Rosner Töchter an Standorten in Bayern
Baden-Württemberg und eben auch Schwedt
so soll gewährleistet werden dass weiter
Öl fließt aber eben nicht aus dem
sanktionierten Russland möglich macht
das das energiesicherungsgesetz genannt
auch lexrossnevt
weil wir gesehen haben dass sich
Versicherer Dienstleister
IT-Dienstleister aber auch Abnehmer
immer stärker zurückgezogen haben und
die Region durch die wichtige Raffinerie
Schwedt in eine Situation hätte geraten
können wo die Versorgung Sicherheit
nicht mehr gegeben ist die Linke
reagiert skeptisch die Unsicherheiten
bleiben die Unsicherheit kommt daher da
keiner weiß woher und wie viel Öl zur
Vollauslastung ab dem ersten ersten
herkommen soll die Schwerter Raffinerie
müsste zu 70% ausgelastet sein um die
Arbeitsplätze zu sichern sagen Fachleute
es bleiben also Fragezeichen
also der raffineriestandort an dem sie
besonders zittern ist PCK im
brandenburgischen Schwedt mehrere
tausend arbeiten dort und für
Zulieferbetriebe und während der Kanzler
von einer Entscheidung zum Schutze
unseres Landes spricht ist die
Verunsicherung in Schwedt groß auf die
Vokabel Treuhand reagieren sie dort
besonders sensibel Katrin Lindner mit
den Reaktionen
wenn die Flamme bei PCK brennt
es Kündigung des russischen ölmagos ab
Januar sind die Sorgen groß in der Stadt
die Nachrichten heute sorgen für
geteilte Meinung eigentlich bin ich froh
dass man jetzt endlich eine Lösung also
eine Lösung in Sicht ist ich finde es
gut das hauptsache es geht weiter
es kann ja nicht sein dass die ganze
Region hier stirbt Treuhand hat man ja
auch viel erlebt nach der Wände
war viele negativ vor dir macht haben
die Treuhand wickelte in der
Nachwendezeit Staatsbetriebe ab legte
sie still oder privatisierte sie viele
wurden entlassen auch beim PCK die
Schwerter Bürgermeisterin ist heute
spontan nach Berlin gefahren zu wichtig
der Termin im Kanzleramt Schwedt bringt
der heutige Tag 825 Millionen Euro und
Jobgarantien wir haben heute
Finanzierungszusagen bekommen und wir
können uns auf den Weg machen sowohl den
Transformationsprozess anzugehen als
auch die Arbeitsplätze vor Ort zu
sichern der heutige Schritt soll
Alternativen zum russischen Öl über
Rostock und Polen möglich machen bisher
sorgt russisches Öl für den Erfolg der
Stadt Unternehmerin Gabriele Manteufel
handelt mit Propangas es fällt bei der
Benzin und diesel-herstellung ab sie
sorgt sich dass es ohne russisches Gas
nicht reichen wird meine grundsätzliche
Befürchtung ist dass die Mengen nicht
zur Verfügung stehen auch wenn die in
der Hand jetzt die Raffinerie übernimmt
ich habe Angst heute gab es Geld und
Garantien doch bis Alternativen zum
russischen Öl funktionieren brauchen sie
in Schwedt auch Zeit
nach den Leichen Funden in der
Ostukraine wird das Ausmaß immer
deutlicher mehr als 400 Tote werden in
einem Waldstück südöstlich der
großstadtkrakev nahe der Stadt isyum
vermutet Exhumierungen durch ukrainische
Ermittler sollen jetzt Klarheit bringen
wie die Opfer zu Tode gekommen sind
Tobias Hefner berichtet
Gräber dicht an dicht in einem Waldstück
bei Ischium im Osten der Ukraine auf
manchen der rund 100 Kreuze die Namen
derer die dort begraben liegen sollen
auf anderen nur eine Nummer oder gar
nichts
Journalisten wurden heute von der
ukrainischen Seite eilig hierher
gebracht die Welt soll Zeuge werden bei
diesem schmerzlichen Fund im
Kriegsgebiet die Aufklärung einer
Mammutaufgabe
man muss jetzt natürlich schauen sind es
Zivilisten oder Soldaten umgebracht
gestorben im Kampf oder vielleicht auch
an fehlender medizinischer Versorgung
diese Wagenkolonne soll Polizei und
Ermittler auf dem Weg zum Fundort zeigen
sie werden Licht ins Dunkel bringen
verspricht die Ukraine
das ist aber nichts was wir in einer
Woche erledigen können wir brauchen
viele Spezialisten Ausrüstung und
besondere Fahrzeuge vor Ort
die Rede ist auch von einzelnen
maßengräbern die die Armee gefunden habe
unabhängig zu belegen ist das derzeit
nicht
wir haben noch nicht genau zählen können
aber in einem großen Grab sind wohl 25
bis 30 Personen bestattet
wie Butcher wo Leichen auf offener
Straße im Frühjahr die Welt schockierten
sei der Fall aber wohl nicht einzuordnen
sagt der Vermissten beauftragte später
und relativiert damit auch Aussagen des
ukrainischen Präsidenten der zuvor einen
solchen Vergleich gezogen hatte
Katrin Eigendorf die war heute in isum
dabei ist inzwischen wieder in rakev
Kathrin das war sicherlich nicht einfach
heute kannst du uns deine Eindrücke
schildern von dem Tag
ja das war eine sehr bedrückende
Situation in diesem Waldstück waren
insgesamt zehn Ermittlerteams damit
beschäftigt dort Leiche für Leiche aus
dem Boden zu holen es herrschte ein
unglaublicher Gestank und man hat auch
manchen der Ermittler angemerkt dass das
wirklich sie überfordert hat man will
jetzt jeden einzelnen Leichnam auf
Spuren untersuchen sind das Menschen die
gewaltsam gestorben sind was ist
wirklich mit ihnen passiert nach
Informationen des Gouverneurs sind
inzwischen ungefähr 50 Leichname
identifiziert worden wovon die große
Mehrheit Spuren von
Gewalteinwirkung trägt also keines
natürlichen Todes gestorben ist das kann
natürlich viel heißen sie können in
einem gewaltsamen Angriff zum Opfer
gefallen sein erschossen worden sein die
Frage ist natürlich auch hat es hier
Folter gegeben gezielte Erschießungen
einige der leichung Leichen so sagt der
Gouverneur habe man gefunden die hatten
die Arme auf dem Rücken zusammen
gefunden einen Leichnam hatte sogar eine
Schlinge um den Hals was auf eine
Erhellung möglicherweise hindeutet es
hat auch Kinder unter den Leichnamen
gegeben man kann die Situation schon aus
einem Grund nicht mit Butcher
vergleichen die Stadt isum so wie viele
hier im Osten und Norden von hakiffanya
über sehr lange Zeit mehr als sechs
Monate von russischen Soldaten besetzt
und die haben wohl immer wieder
Kommandos auch losgeschickt und dafür
gesorgt dass tote aufgesammelt und eben
dort in diesem Waldstück ja in die Erde
gesagt lassen wurden von Begräbnis kann
man da nicht reden sondern die wurden
einfach in der Erde verscharrt und dann
kreuzte darauf gesetzt und bis jetzt ist
eigentlich auch nicht klar wie viele
Menschen unter den einzelnen kreuzen
dann vergraben sind das wird sich alles
noch zeigen müssen die Aufklärung dieses
Falles steht noch ganz am Anfang und die
Ermittler gehen davon aus dass sie
alleine für die Bergung der Leichen noch
eine Woche brauchen werden danke für
eine Schilderung nach hakif Kathrin
Eigendorf war das
die Bundeswehr werde sich künftig wieder
auf ihre Kernaufgabe konzentrieren
Landes- und bündnisverteidigung alle
anderen Aufgaben hätten sich dem
unterzuordnen kündigte Bundeskanzler
Scholz auf einer bundeswehrtagung in
Berlin an er erneuerte auch seine Zusage
des künftig zwei Prozent der
Wirtschaftsleistung in die Verteidigung
investiert werde außerdem war ab Scholz
für mehr europäische Zusammenarbeit bei
Rüstungsexporten
der Herbst kommt mit großen Schritten
und mit der kälteren Jahreszeit
vielleicht auch wieder eine neue
corona-infektionswelle und deshalb gibt
es bundesweit wieder neue Regeln die der
Bundesrat heute verabschiedet hat ab dem
1 Oktober gilt die
ffp2-maskenpflicht in Krankenhäusern
Pflegeheimen Arztpraxen und im
Fernverkehr der Bahn fürs Fliegen wurde
die maskenpflicht aufgehoben in letzter
Sekunde gestrichen wurde die geplante
testpflicht für Kinder und Jugendliche
wenn der Verdacht einer Infektion
besteht mehr von Daniel Pons
18 + 9
10 20 Berlin 6 Klasse heute morgen noch
hustet noch schnieft niemand laut neuem
Infektionsschutzgesetz sollte das als
mögliches Symptom künftig schon reichen
um nicht mehr in die Schule zu dürfen
oder in die Kita auch ein freitesten
nach fünf Tagen sollte obligatorisch
werden anders als bei Berufstätigen so
wollte er es beides wurde von
Kinderärzten die unionsgeführten Ländern
scharf kritisiert und nun in letzter
Sekunde kassiert das wäre eine deutlich
strengere Regelung gewesen als alles was
wir bisher gehabt haben für Kinder und
Jugendlichen und das in der Endphase
einer Pandemie wo zumindest die jetzigen
Varianten ja deutlich mildere Verläufe
vor allem auch für Kinder und
Jugendliche haben Lauterbach heute im
Bundesrat zu Gast hatte unter dem Druck
der Länder eingelenkt nach Endphase der
Pandemie klang er weiterhin nicht ich
möchte nicht dass wir uns daran gewöhnen
dass jeden Tag 150 oder gar 200 Menschen
in Zukunft jeden Tag an sarskow sterben
und zum Teil sterben das ist nicht der
Tod den man sich selbst oder seinen
geliebten Menschen wünscht und das ist
der Grund weshalb ich dieses Gesetz erst
das Gesetz wurde mit deutlicher Mehrheit
verabschiedet kritik kam vor allem aus
Thüringen unter anderem an der
Fortsetzung der einrichtungsbezogenen
Impfpflicht und an mangelnder
Einbeziehung der Länder vorab die
Ministerpräsidenten sind erst gar nicht
gefragt worden das ist durchaus für mich
eine neue Lebenserfahrung nach
zweieinhalb Jahren pandemiearbeit dass
wir jetzt auf einmal zur Kenntnis nehmen
dass wir zweieinhalb Jahre vorne auf der
ersten Reihe stehen durften und jetzt
nicht mal mehr gefragt werden aufatmen
unterdessen in vielen Schulen ob es ab
Klasse 5 wieder zu einer maskenpflicht
kommt entscheiden die Länder je nach
Lage
erst Trockenheit dann Überschwemmungen
in Italien sind bei schweren Unwettern
mindestens zehn Menschen ums Leben
gekommen mehrere werden vermisst
besonders betroffen ist die Region
Marken an der Adriaküste dort regnet es
letzte Nacht binnen Stunden so viel wie
bisher in sechs Monaten Michael Verlad
violand und Holger Müller berichten
und plötzlich kommt das Wasser
unaufhaltsam Straßen verschwinden ein
knochentrockener Sommer endet in einer
Sintflut eine Nacht wie sie die Mitte
Italiens wohl nur selten erlebt hat
man kann sich kaum vorstellen wie es
hier aussah Donner und Blitz
unbeschreiblich ich bin 80 Jahre alt
aber so etwas habe ich noch nie gesehen
plötzlich stand das Wasser so hoch
mal schauen wir packen es jetzt an
aber es wird hart
die Menschen graben sich durch Tonnen
von klebrigen Schlamm glücklich die
Gemeinde die schweres Gerät zur
Verfügung hat es gab Warnungen der
Meteorologen doch die Behörden wurden
vom Ausmaß der Wassermassen überrascht
es hat in diesem Gebiet innerhalb
einiger Stunden ein Drittel der Menge
geregnet die Songs in einem ganzen Jahr
regnet in manchen Gebieten hat es
doppelt so viel geregnet wie es
normalerweise im Sommer regnet
aus der Luft das ganze Bild der
Katastrophe hier wählt das Flüsschen
mieser sein schlammiges Wasser in die
azurblaue Adria Hubschrauber sind in der
Luft vier Menschen werden noch vermisst
neuer Regen droht an Italiens Adriaküste
jetzt zu einer umstrittenen Ausstellung
im Kunstmuseum Bern denn der zu sehende
bilderschatz stammt aus dem Besitz des
deutsch-österreichers Cornelius Gurlitt
sie erinnern sich der Fall hatte 2013
für Aufsehen gesorgt in Görlitz
Münchener Wohnung hatten zollfan eine
riesige Sammlung entdeckt money Mark
Liebermann lauter große Namen und der
inzwischen verstorbene gurlet vermachte
das meiste dem Berner Museum ein heikles
Geschenk denn viele der Bilder könnten
nazi-raubkunst sein nur welche dazu
jetzt Simone Friedrich
der Platz an der Wand hat nicht gereicht
für die Kopien von allen 1600 Werken des
coliterbes die Menge ist überwältigend
die einzelnen Werke sind auch Claude
Monet August oder Paul Sesam mit dem
Erbe hat das Museum eine gewaltige
Aufgabe übernommen es war klar dass man
ein solches Erbe nicht annimmt um ein
paar Meisterwerke mehr der Sammlung
einzuverleiben sondern dass man so ein
Erbe annimmt um Verantwortung auch für
die Geschichte dieser Sammlung zu
übernehmen Erbe verpflichtet es wurde
eine eigene Abteilung zur
Provenienzforschung gegründet in wessen
Besitz war dieses Werk von Wilhelm
lachnitt handelt es sich bei dem Griebel
Gemälde um Raubkunst gibt es
Manipulationen an Leinwand Farbe oder
Rahmen gibt es noch Unterlagen von
Museen oder Gestapo eine Spurensuche
auch bei diesen Aquarellen von Otto Dix
Dame in der Loge und dompteuse hier gab
es deutliche Hinweise auf Kunst eines
der wichtigsten Dokumente für die
Identifizierung ist tatsächlich der
Versteigerungskatalog und zum anderen
die Gestapo Beschlagnahme
beziehungsweise die
gestapo-beschlagnahme wird auch nur
greifbar anhand der Unterlagen
die sich eben im Zentralarchiv der
Berliner Museen erhalten haben bei den
meisten Werken nur Hinweise auf die
Herkunft keine Gewissheit trotzdem wurde
entschieden die dixaquarelle
zurückzugeben an die Erben eines
jüdischen Rechtsanwaltes eine innovative
und wenn es nach dem Kunstmuseum Bern
geht eine richtungweisende Lösung
über Jahrzehnte prägte er das
öffentlich-rechtliche Fernsehen jetzt
ist der Journalist und frühere WDR
Intendant Fritz Pleitgen im Alter von 84
Jahren gestorben der gebürtige
Duisburger arbeitete seit 1963 beim WDR
und leitete den Sender von 1995 bis 2007
er galt als einer der einflussreichsten
deutschen Journalisten und Medienmacher
als ARD-Korrespondent berichtete unter
anderem aus Ostberlin und Moskau
wir sind jetzt beim Sport Katja ich kann
es ruhig sagen ich bin großer basketball
fan und ich freue mich auf heute Abend
ja heute Abend wird es ernst und ein
paar mehr Zuschauer als sonst werden es
wohl sein vielleicht sogar Millionen vom
Fernseher die da mit fiebern und allein
14.000 sind es in der ausverkauften
Arena unweit des Berliner Ostbahnhofs
wenn Deutschland heute Abend im
EM-Halbfinale Weltmeister Spanien
empfängt sie haben sich warm gespielt in
der Halle die sie im Halbfinale gegen
Spanien zum Kochen bringen wollen
Medaille und wenn du so kurzer vor bist
wissen natürlich
ist natürlich den Potter zu auch noch
haben Bundestrainer Gordon Herbert
stehen gegen Weltmeister Spanien zwölf
Spieler zur Verfügung und mit diesem
eingespielten fokussierten Team scheint
alles möglich getragen vom Publikum
haben die Deutschen um Kapitän Dennis
Schröder sechs von sieben EM-Spielen
gewonnen ein Sieg heute Abend würde die
erste Medaille seit 2005 bedeuten
er historisches ist gestern Abend der
deutschen da ja fahrvolle mega gelungen
sie holte bei den Weltmeisterschaften in
der Rhythmischen Sportgymnastik in Sofia
Bulgarien Gold mit den Keulen und damit
den ersten Titel für Deutschland seit 47
Jahren die 15-Jährige machte damit den
wm-medaillensatz komplett nach Silber
mit dem Ball und Bronze mit dem Reifen
nun also noch die Goldmedaille
und morgen steigt das 181 Revier Derbi
Borussia Dortmund empfängt in der
Fußball-Bundesliga den FC Schalke 04 die
Bilanz der letzten Jahrzehnte spricht
für wiederaufsteiger Schalke die
Gegenwart aber klar für den Vizemeister
BVB
die Pandemie der Abstieg Schalke
bereitet sich auf das erste Derby seit
fast drei Jahren in einem vollen Stadion
vor der BVB verlor Mittwoch gegen
Manchester City hat dennoch stark
gespielt aber noch eine Niederlage im
Derby dann geht es weitere hitzige
Diskussionen in Dortmund glauben Sie mir
es gibt auch in meinem Leben als als
Trainer vom BVB würde es nichts
Schlimmeres geben als dem Schalker
Trainer zum Sieg zu gratulieren Schalke
feierte zuletzt gegen Bochum den ersten
Sieg der Saison Frank Kramer würde es
sicher gefallen wenn Terzic ihn zum
nächsten gratulieren müsste
und alles zum Derby und mehr morgen
Abend natürlich im Aktuellen Sportstudio
dann danke Katja für den freitagssport
das noch vorweg morgen unbeständig kühl
und windig mehr Wetter gleich mit
Christa Orden um 22 Uhr empfehlen wir
das heute journal mit Christian Sievers
ja das war die Nachrichtenlage am
Freitag entspannten Start jetzt ins
Wochenende und bis morgen wenn Sie mögen
[Musik]
guten Abend zwischen diesem Tief über
Skandinavien und diesem hoch über dem
britischen Inseln fließt weiter diese
höhenkalte Luft zu uns ein darunter das
Meer ist noch recht mild und deswegen
erstehen diese Schauer und Gewitter mit
denen wir es jetzt am Wochenende zu tun
bekommen das ist eben auch heute Nacht
der Fall von der Nordsee herkommen
Schauer und Gewitter weiter ins Land wir
haben auch so ein kompakteres
Regengebiet dass ich über Niedersachsen
und Nordrhein-Westfalen langsam weiter
südlich schiebt und auch an den Alpen
haben wir etwas ergiebigeren Regen der
fällt oberhalb von 1500 Metern auch als
Schnee und das ist dann richtig
herbstlich morgen früh zumal ist hier
nur Temperaturen um die 5 Grad gibt an
der milderen See sind es immerhin 11 12
Grad morgen gibt es an den Alpen dann
Höchstwerte von nur acht Grad an der
Havel sind das 17 Grad dazu ist es
wieder sehr windig morgen an der Nord
sind auf dem Brocken im Harz sind
Sturmböen möglich es ist wechselnd
bewölkt immer wieder Schauer und vor
allem an der See und über
artikelgebirgen gibt es auch einzelne
Gewitter etwas kompakter sind die Wolken
und auch der Regen im Süden des Landes
im Stau der Alpen und am Sonntag geht es
unbeständig und windig weiter erst am
Montag kommt vom Südwesten langsam eine
Wetterberuhigung tschüss